[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
taka soir c'est la plaine
10e jour l'ardenne
j'entendais fois que la moisson revanche
comme je savoir faute à vous
[Musique]
ben oui grand spectacle en pourquoi
parce que c'est jour de fête nationale
pour les acadiens un peu partout
d'ailleurs un peu plus tôt il ya eu la
période le grand tintamarre sas est
connu maintenant lé grand rassemblement
qui font du bruit pour rappeler et
réaffirmer la fierté acadienne on va
parler tout ça à dieppe en direct au
nouveau brunswick avec louise imbeault
c'est la présidente de la société
nationale de l'acadie vont sommes là
demain bonnes fêtes
merci et bonne soirée madame drolet
dites moi qu'est ce que ça représente
encore aujourd'hui on est en 2010 9 9
célébrer la fête nationale les occasions
vous dire quoi
mais vous savez les acadiens qui ont été
dispersés en 17 7 755 pendant sept ou
huit années sont revenus ont eu
l'autorisation de revenir sur les
territoires à condition de se disperser
de ne pas faire front commun
alors on a eu une grande période qu'on
appelait l'enracinement dans le silence
ça dirige durer jusqu en 1881
et à partir de ce moment là le peuple
acadien a décidé qu'il lui fallait des
symboles un drapeau un hymne national
une fête nationale 1 devise aussi
l'union fait la force et depuis ce temps
là dedans depuis 135 ans on n'a pas
cessé de rappeler aux personnes avec qui
on partage le territoire dans les
provinces atlantiques mais ailleurs
aussi à travers le monde qu'on était là
pour rester qu'on était là pour parler
français et qu on allait se donner
toutes les institutions nécessaires pour
le poker s'assumer à l'anglophonie mais
qu'on reste bel et bien partie de la
francophonie
expliquez moi ce que ça veut dire
aujourd'hui être acadien par les
français dans le quotidien qu'on est
hors du québec
quand on est dans le territoire à
quelqu'un comme tel est ce qui a encore
un petit côté combes d'assumer qu'on
parle en français était d'utiliser cette
langue là dans les services dans les
commerces comment ça se passe vous posez
bien la question mais je veux simplement
vous dire que la réalité pour nous et
pas une comparaison avec le québec
on occupe un territoire qui est
différent on a une histoire qui est
différente et on s'enracine
dans notre territoire même si les
disperser même s'il est à la grandeur
des provinces atlantiques et un peu
partout à travers le monde mais oui
effectivement on est obligé de continuer
de demander on est obligé de continuer
de réclamer on est obligé aussi de se
convaincre nous mêmes qu'on est capable
de ces grandes visions vision de gérer
nos institutions de créer nos propres
institutions de se donner les outils de
développement qu'on le souhaite avoir
et la société acadienne au fait tout ça
à travers les années il l'a fait à
l'intérieur d'elle-même bien sûr en
s'appuyant sur les connaissances en
s'appuyant sur des recherches mais on se
lisait inventé ces façon de s'affirmer
en partie parce que le peuple acadien
est un peuple pacifique qui a appris à
travers les années à composer avec la
réalité mais sans jamais lancé la
serviette sans jamais abandonner
ouais c'est vraiment un exemple de
résilience de courage de détermination
aussi puis de cultiver la fierté de la
culture comporte
là vous avez les granges les chefs des
grands partis
on sait qu'on est alors d'une campagne
électorale bien entendu pour la première
fois on dit après 15 ans d'efforts le
ottawa a annoncé pour la première fois
une contribution financière directe pour
les célébrations de la fête nationale se
faisait longtemps que c'est demandé avez
vous l'impression que aujourd'hui et
demain avez vous l'impression que les
policiers son lob sont plus attentifs
parce qu'une campagne électorale c'est à
dire est ce que votre leur capacité est
sensible à vos enjeux et variable en
fonction si on arrive dans une année
électorale ou pas non seulement parce
qu'elle campagne électorale probablement
mais aussi parce que on a au canada une
loi qui s'appelle la loi sur les langues
officielles qui est vraiment un contrat
social au canada entre les anglophones
et les francophones
ce contrat social existe depuis 50 ans
mais ça fait déjà quelques années que
les acadiens francophones mais aussi les
autres francophones du pays réclame une
modernisation de cette loi là après 50
ans la loi n'est pas parfaitement
appliqué on est obligé encore de
réclamer un objet parfois d'aller en
cours alors là on veut qu'elle est parti
politique qui soit prennent
un engagement sur la modernisation de
cette loi et sur le fait de la rendre
beaucoup plus qu'attrayante pour les
organismes fédéraux qui pensent qu'ils
ont pas besoin de l'appliquer que ça
c'est la sphère de patrimoine que c'est
la peur des langues officielles mais que
eux ont pas besoin de s'en charger alors
ce message là on l'a dit aussi
aujourd'hui malgré les faibles bien
qu'on était en période de célébration on
a rappelé devant les politiciens qui
étaient là dans l'assemblée ni qu'on
comptait sur eux sur elle pour prendre
position sur cette voie là pour la
renouveler
et pour faire que elle s'applique
beaucoup plus facilement sans peau soit
obligée d'aller en cours par exemple
pour qu'on soit obligé de faire des
manifestations de tous genres pour que
la loi soit appliquée mais madame un bon
on va vous laisser retourner fêter parce
que là c'est vraiment la période
spectacle la période où les gens sont
contents et le vivant français ce serait
très bien entendu et encore une fois
bonne fête nationale et à tous nos amis
un caddie qui sont allés cote
actuellement commerce
merci beaucoup